ne vous inquiétez pas vous êtes toujours
sur martinique 1ère et votre téléviseur
n'a aucun problème de réception
nous sommes dans la salle du restaurant
au noir et c'est exactement dans ces
conditions c'est à dire dans le noir
total que sont installés de convives
mais si vous tendez bien l'oreille vous
pouvez deviner ce qui s'y passe fort
heureusement nos chefs cuisiniers eux on
doit à la lumière et c'est appréciable
lorsque l'on sait les plats qu'ils
entendent préparer
qu'est ce que vous préparez nathanel à
la note jean glavany
[Musique]
cinq points des prix et un petit coup de
gueule le bénéfice est la particularité
c'est que le
l'ebit s'est fait avec de la farine
rob patates douces riz amer dans sa
mitaine pour les convives entrés en file
indienne dans le restaurant pendant les
deux prochaines heures ils ne verront
aucune lumière
[Musique]
ici le personnel et non ou malvoyants
aujourd'hui ils ont aussi pour mission
de rapporter les réponses des invités
qui doivent deviner le contenu de leur
assiette
la dame numéro 1 ananas mangue moisn
gingembre à la sortie les visages en
disent long sur la singularité de
l'expérience
c'est formidable l'extraordinaire la
nourriture et des excellentes on a
vraiment adoré l'expérience serait
jamais vu c'est ma ville a jamais jamais
jamais et au moment de la découverte des
plats les surprises sont nombreuses
il a qui ont dit que les sofina qui ont
dit autre chose
patate douce là on a dit crevettes
tigrées du mexique s'est pas trompé
l'idée c'était de jouer un petit peu
sous les textures puisqu'on est dans le
noir et on voit pas forcément le plat du
classement sectoriel est intéressante et
puis on a collaboré avec les chefs et
aussi bien amusé une expérience
culinaire qui va se prolonger pour
l'heureuse gagnante
ces bonnes réponses lui ont permis de
gagner un voyage en martinique